[Music]
three two one action
hey guys welcome back to off-the-record
where we talk about whatever we want I
want to talk about our trip talking
about something I want to talk about you
whale how was it
well I where hi Joe because of white
people push me to it
well white people I made friends yeah at
the sushi bar Japanese are the ones
killing whales
yeah but the white people are the ones
exploring and eating it when Bakula like
freaking 14 hundreds no because I wasn't
gonna do it and I was eating sushi with
my nephews and then these guys were
having trouble at the restaurant so I
was like Oh Americans and I was like
helping them out and we were talking and
then you know it was like what do you
call it rotating sushi bar and then this
side comes up and it says well and in my
cousins like my nephews like is that
really well and then they read the
Japanese partner like oh [ __ ] it is and
then the two guys were like oh really
and then they ordered it and I was like
oh damn how was it and I was like well
if they got if they're gonna do I got to
do it - it didn't even push you yeah
they did it
yeah they did because they say those
delicious you should try it and I was
like did it if these white guys are
gonna do it and I count with you dude
what they did they Yelp reviewed it and
you were like they pushed me was it good
it was a good news I don't know because
you don't know how much I had so much
tuna already in my mouth never just
tasted like tuna but it was really soft
like imagine Oh Trippi you could get
that with eel then you would know it's
not it's like filet mignon like but
imagine like read me but it's softer
yeah it's really soft
you've tried it - no I didn't I did not
Nikki we well right oh yeah seared but
no I did it I did it
did you go you guys ate it last time
Thank You Gio the only decent human
close-minded is he
the sea that's [ __ ] up what's wrong
with eating whale because they're like
humans of the scene dolphins are humans
of the ship those are the dogs of the
sea
those are the human whatever you I bet
you need a dolphin to you [ __ ] evil
people I would eat a dolphin easy oh my
god I thought dog in Korea on the menu I
was like wow Daniel why all dogs
Steve's brother was stationed in Korea
for a while and he did it and it were
wild thought the free-range free-range
documents organic dog just dog and then
there's dog yeah oh you would eat
document I'm not gonna eat your pet
[ __ ] that's true there's fish it
in there's gold fish species yeah I'll
eat a human - I don't give a [ __ ] what
if someone someone had salmon at the
pound go buy wheat that's a dumb pet
dumb pet dog is a smart bet a dog is a
smart person on papers and or pigs yeah
but a lot of people do never eaten pig
in my life you're like well I ate it
when I was a kid and I was like it was
disgusting enough blacks are pretty
smart too dude I don't have feelings too
you eat goldfish I know I don't hear
them scream boy goldfish fancy fish
tetras you're okay with all of that fish
I'm okay with but like I wouldn't eat a
tropical fish because they're not like
your your racist you know what's good I
see a species I had this epiphany when I
was [ __ ] high as [ __ ] so they'll get
ready for the rest of these words that
come out of my mouth to be stupid
alright so as you know I was a
vegetarian for like a few years yeah in
college so then I was high as [ __ ] and
then I was sitting there and I was
looking at how fishermen bring the fish
out of the ocean and they just dump them
on their ship right and these fish are
[ __ ] suffocating because they just
don't have water and I'm like bro and
then they get hooks they hook them and
then they put them in like this conveyer
thing you're making me salivate and it's
[ __ ] up and it's the mall
most [ __ ] inhumane way to kill an
animal by suffocation dude and I was
like I'm never eating fish guys and you
love sushi
I know I know I'm just being that's the
worst way to kill an animal is my
[ __ ] suffocation you only fish that's
bull I hate the way we do cuz you're
thinking of suffocation like this
what if for them they're just like Oh
tambri what does that mean what do you
mean yep I mean but they're just they
can focus your your your your trying to
empathize with the fish they don't have
emotions the same allocate the way that
you do yeah they go through so much more
[ __ ] than when we do maybe so for them
even going to the bottom of the ocean to
the top of the ocean they're already
releasing they're getting deep
pressurized so by getting deep
pressurized are not even suffocating the
same way that we are maybe we don't know
that maybe no I do know that scientists
oh ok ok almost maybe stop eating fish
was all these videos popped up of my
YouTube feed recently where they were
like showing you how they take the
parasites out of fish and how like
pretty much every single sushi tuna has
parasites in it and I'm like the [ __ ] I
eat yo tell I could give a [ __ ] yeah but
watching it I but watching it there's a
difference between hearing it and then
seeing it oh but there's but see I think
you're also very detached like I grew up
where I saw chickens get their head
chopped off and I ate it so like that's
not a pair of things about everything
you have has bacteria parasites if you
were like you know [ __ ] see [ __ ] like
through a microscope you see all this
[ __ ] off Snickers while the dog is
taking a [ __ ] in front of me things are
like earthworms they're like this long
and they're like thick they're not
likely to to a group of [ __ ] people
in straightjackets right now okay
anyways first you didn't want me to eat
fish now you want me to eat fish I don't
know what you want from me but I'm just
saying parasites and we can all hang out
you could be vegetarian you cannot be it
could be carnivore boy you could be
callable boy and we can argue
I agree but [ __ ] whales Bart and dogs
I'm drawing the line might be delicious
we all ate whale here no not we monsters
that whale [ __ ] deserved it be it was
born into an ocean where it was gonna be
eaten anyways by another way it was not
an another kind of where are you
imagining a big blue whale
what are the whale are they're really
yeah not even a killer whale you see the
family oh let me get back to the texture
though it's soft it is my mom said that
she likes it more than Toro Wow I like
Toro
yeah yeah well you guys didn't make it
what do we get to see me like medieval
times of Japan you didn't really get it
rotating sushi bar that we had - oh you
tried it twice yeah and it tasted the
same it tasted just minerally yeah I
don't had it seared but the seared was
anyway moving on helis approved by one
oh my god taiwan was so [ __ ] hot it
looks beautiful it was beautiful but I
hated everyone I see because it's not
just us racist
it's human just one picture of Tiger
befel looked like he dumped into a pool
what happened a little oven already
likens it like that humid hot where you
can't breathe because you just feel like
you get hit so we had this really nice
hotel right and as soon as the elevator
doors open for you to go outside it was
like this wall of moist [ __ ] Samoan
breathing heat on your [ __ ] body dude
it was it was unlivable I loved it
though when you're in Taiwan it's okay
for me
I really you like how hot it is when I'm
in Taiwan it's fun better like I don't
mind it I was there in December and I
thought it was too that's yeah
when did you go oh I think it was very
September yeah cuz that's the fall
yeah that's the end of sign it's [ __ ]
hot if you get hotter than that it's oh
no no August is the worst August is the
worst 100 no it was like 83 but the
humidity that's the [ __ ] that [ __ ] you
up it was yeah I didn't want to do [ __ ]
but you'll sit there literally just sit
there and you're just starting to sweat
for no reason perfuse Lee I'm not even
moving what the [ __ ] is going on and
this was in cow song right so then once
we were going home it was [ __ ] hot so
then from cow Sean we have to go to
Taipei and then Taipei was immediately
like livable way cooler my the coastal
side area right yeah yeah yeah oh you
there's probably like a 10 20 degree
temperature difference that's what I was
like hey [ __ ] you should have
gone to Bali oh we went for his family
not so my vacation oh I thought you're
going for you sure
Oh your family's in Thailand yeah my
uncle is there and then his daughter
just graduated dental schools where she
moved back over there and then they've
seen tyka when he was maybe like two or
three months old so and they really
really love them well six months how was
the food oh I got stinky tofu the best
in the world specialized in stinky tofu
and it's so poppin it's a two-story
restaurant and that's all they sell it
stinky tofu wait I think I've seen it on
oh is it the is it the cold kind or is
this is a fried one on the firemen yeah
we smelled see it oh so bomb [ __ ] and
then put it in your toilet what does he
want to eat it then cuz it tasted bomb
as not taste but you just like to say
that you like it cause it's like cuz
there's like everyone else
that grew up on it they smell something
else they smell garlic or something else
we all smell caca
it smells like sewer like literally
sewer smells a little bit better don't
do it like that's true what do you think
about durian have you ever had that
yeah that's true Malaysia was pretty
good and that one makes sense because
it's sweet okay whereas and that doesn't
it just tastes like a little bit more
vinegary tofu and I'm like I'll just
stick to the regular ngon [ __ ] vinegar
for some reason no one can fry it as
good as the stinky tofu fryer please I
don't know mad cuz I have fried tofu
before and it's the same thing without
the smell of [ __ ] that's specifically oh
there's no quiz that can fry a tofu like
that I don't know why I don't give it I
would like to get used
you could put a thousand dollars on that
[ __ ] how many go touching that because
you're not though eating two is pretty
nasty because there's like a [ __ ]
like a string that falls more of like a
texture thing but not don't once you put
like the soil funky it does smell it
smells like toes smells like smells like
pen Jong to me which is the same thing
it's soy beans fermented soya oh yeah
yeah okay just say that are used we're
in America yeah fermented soy bean is
super long and pendulum a fester you be
cultured all right you Mexican Filipino
I mean like places that are like
specializing in not toe though it's
always like a little side thing that's
in Taiwan you have like places that are
just stinky tofu yeah like I watch this
Andrew Z one where he went in oh you
know the place that Andrews II went
right that's the place I went oh place
is the one that has the longest
fermented stinky tofu it's kind of that
one imagine the smell of tofu and then
Taiwan it's a bunch of scooters so
there's like [ __ ] fumes oh yeah and
then it's humid so it's hot stinky [ __ ]
with gas yeah that's true it smells like
gas the older fermented one that just
looks like sewage I actually prefer that
over the fine one because the fried one
it because it's fried you have to chew
on it and it just blackheads
[ __ ] chew with your mouth closed
though I just can't that's what I look
like when I eat it but then that the the
smooth one they put like a sweet soy
over it and like some other [ __ ] so it's
[Music]
just don't understand I just don't
understand I saw a couple feet each
other it's so funny how was Korea I love
how global everyone is yeah yeah yeah
we're really global hey you you go to
Bali and talk about it damn I'm here to
listen Joe I'm just saying I'm not
global in this conversation you been to
a lot of places that's the past me this
me and this year have not been to very
many places what to Mexico I went to New
Zealand earlier cuñado Sarita and then
swin [ __ ] your husband really want to
hear about Costa places you were like
Jukes I haven't been a Korean so long oh
it was awesome it was really really
really wonderful it was a trip because I
felt like Casey and I kept comparing it
to Cape Town like this is literally yeah
a huge way cleaner no homeless people or
Mexican that's a town that's what it
feels like
right yeah doesn't it feel like little
America yeah like it's kind of mixed
works like a little bit Japanese a
little bit of American but like a lot of
k-town feels um yeah yeah like the
buildings and like yeah yeah it was
beautiful
yeah that's what they didn't soul the
whole time so it was really dope because
the Tourism Board brought us out so they
really wanted us to see like Korea
through there I was tight and so we got
to do a lot of really traditional Korean
stuff like what like we made our own
seal which is like even though I'm with
you feels like thank you
no like a stamps field
yeah Game of Thrones real quick no I'm
so used to you guys eating like I saw
Casey with the octopus he ate that no we
did it
okay never we did not eat that so I got
sad too you could see it under story but
not anymore tires really smart wait for
the mother they also taste good to close
your ears so it was amazing cuz they've
chopped it up right in front of you and
as soon as they give it to you because
here we've only had two here before so
they have to bring it from the kitchen
to the table but I guess the table the
texture is really like rubbery probably
try to tell you yes so then but since we
were sitting right in front of her after
she chopped it was always soft amazing
were you sitting in front of the
aquarium it was three feet it was like
that's [ __ ] tragic oh you're talking
about eating octopus alive no no no
we're not oh so we're talking about
varsity ball that they plucked out of
the dirt I'm just gonna say at least at
least kill it for [ __ ] seen a sea
turtle chomp on a [ __ ] octopus give a
[ __ ] are you a sea turtle
yes I am how did you not know makes
sense
cute no but we also learned how to dance
to a kpop song so I like that better I
like this part oh that's part of the
Tourism Board what was the whole thing
with Isaac in a recording booth that's
so heat so we had this opportunity to
record our own kpop site we're not our
own like we're caught it was a BTS boy
with love it's like the Mia was hit and
and so because my voice was gone and KC
had a lot of phlegm we couldn't do it no
is this one other girl that joint cuz
everyone that they invited out we all
split up into different themes of Korea
and we were in the kpop / beauty theme
so I got to go to a spa get a facial
last one yeah and then but the the
recording the song part I couldn't do it
boys right so then this other girl that
was in our group and Isaac had to record
the song all time they had to or not I
mean they did it sounds good it sounds
it sounds really Korean to me that's
what you have they got the real kpop
experience when the manager beat them up
yeah and then somebody sexually harass
you as well Wow oh damn they were like
when we entered the recording studio
though they were like do you guys know
any k-pop artists were like no we've
never heard like anything or anything
and so they started naming all these
artists they were like yeah they
recorded here so you're gonna be using
the exact same microphone that'd be like
you're gonna be like oh my god if you
were a huge kpop fan though you would
have [ __ ] came in your pants like I
was trying to appreciate like this is
amazing
other people would for sure like [ __ ]
guy in this room true I'll be like oh
they use this mic and I started looking
the [ __ ] mic like crazy like I've
literally seen this girl at this kpop
event in k-town she started balling just
cuz they went on stage like I couldn't
breathe type of [ __ ] it was it's kind of
crazy like I don't understand I don't
understand the connection yeah because
we're huge fans of people here in the
states I would never cry like I would be
like yo Michael that's dope I wouldn't
be like okay with Eminem but it wasn't
like that
but I cried with Eminem but not when I
was a teenager like I never got it when
I was a teenager like all the fangirling
and screaming but after 20 years of
being a fan and going to a concert I
cried because it was like each song took
me back to a different place in my life
and it's just like this guy that's been
like a constant in my whole entire life
and I've never had that with any other
artist before you're a [ __ ] freak
Jackson came back to life I do it if you
was a zombie like like in thriller and
he came back to life and I could
understand that too but some of these
guys only been out for like two years I
see that I never got when I was like a
15 year old then I went to his concert
that was at the peak of his career and I
was excited to be there but I'm excited
you're like oh [ __ ] yeah like yeah but I
was never like my babies I was I never
understood that some of these girls
passed not to seeing these dudes at like
a 7-eleven yeah they died well that's
why I'm an ominous ever loved and I
chipped my pants but oh really we have
fans that cry sometimes you never had
that yeah was it that moment when I was
a your mom or was at that time when was
it that really touched you like what was
it that I said it's a connection that
they see you in your in their room every
day like they're watching you every day
in the room at least for me it was like
I was listening to Eminem every day in
my room so like they hear your voice
they see your face every single day they
feel like they know you and then you can
see them in person it's like oh my god
curse you out and they call you stupid
you were responsible for so many moments
in my life yeah
[Music]
[Music]